when we're
examining and encountering various views
on what philosophy is and also what
philosophy isn't we get
characterizations coming from a number
of different perspectives and you could
say that there is no consensus
on precisely what counts as philosophy
and what doesn't
and what's better what's worse what's
closer to the
core or essence or definition of it
and i think it could be helpful in order
to
cut through some of this confusion to
distinguish between
a few different ways in which we use
this term philosophy to
to signify and to signal to point out
some aspects some dimensions of it that
are interconnected
and that people might have in mind so
you know there's philosophy
itself as a discipline as something
that is taught that is passed on
from generation of teachers to students
and and you know through the ages uh
there's also a professional discipline
that arises
really in the west you could say
you know in in the current way that we
understand
it from about the 19th century on
although definitely there was philosophy
as a discipline in universities
before that there's philosophy as a
literature
as things that we can actually point to
when ge
moore famously was asked to define
philosophy and he gestured at his
bookshelf and said well it's all of this
stuff
here that's philosophy as literature and
and we can talk about you know where the
boundaries of that
are is it different than history or
religious studies or theology and
there's there's something to that as
well
and then you know we can think of
philosophy as in another way
how do we actually wind up with a
discipline how do we wind up with a
literature that we can
read or take in in some way
philosophy is a kind of activity
and it's very often construed
as something like you know the top
level activity that other
kinds of activities often represented by
disciplines and literatures
flow into so it could be the science of
sciences
or it could be you know what happens
when we're getting more
questioning and abstraction going on
so there's there's a lot to be said
about the activity of the human mind and
we could also say
not just a single human mind human minds
in relation to each other
that constitutes philosophizing and then
we can also talk about
philosophy as something like a
vocation that some people
take as their orienting principle their
life's work
uh as their way of life
and there is indeed something that is
called philosophy as a way of life that
has become
recognized since the you know midpoint
of the 20th century
onward associated with that great phrase
philosophy is a way of life with pure
odd dull but
existing throughout the ages and
and you know in fact a lot of ancient
and medieval
and early modern philosophy was
philosophy as a way of of life and
all four of these and this is not an ex
you know
entirely comprehensive mapping here but
all four of these
are interconnected with each other and
so when people
are debating or arguing with each other
well that's not philosophy and no this
is philosophy is this the best
philosophy
one person might be thinking in terms of
philosophy as a discipline we don't
study that here in our philosophy
department
you can say well why not it's
philosophical
literature it could lead to a certain
way of living you may be using the same
mental activities capacities
dispositions to do it as with other
things that we call
philosophy just doesn't happen to be
taught here instead it gets taught you
know like for example alexis de
tocqueville
who's clearly a philosopher gets taught
in political science departments more
often than in
philosophy departments and you know we
could also talk about you know
too exclusive a focus on is it published
or not
well you know socrates didn't publish a
single thing people published things
about him including plato
and xenophon but also eskinese and a few
other people
writing socratic dialogues you know
is is that important that somebody has
books articles blog posts
whatever to their account somebody might
focus entirely
on philosophy as an activity and say oh
you know i'm not a fuddy-duddy
like those people in the philosophy
department or the people who are
beholden enslaved to the literature of
philosophy i'm gonna
make new paths for myself unfortunately
what you find out is
usually when somebody claims to be doing
that
you look in the literature and
somebody's already done what they're
doing including that very same i'm
breaking with tradition
right and all of these you know kind of
come together
and reinforce each other it could be
useful
to think about you know a prototypical
set of philosophers and think about how
they
figure into this so let's take socrates
for example right
socrates very very clearly
thinks that philosophy is not just an
activity
and could become a discipline although
it's not really a discipline in his time
but he you know he sketches out at least
according to plato
some some modes in which that could take
place but he
definitely practiced philosophy as a way
of life
and as a vocation to the point that it
got him killed where he tells them
hey if you're going to tell me to stop
philosophizing or
be executed go ahead and execute me
right
philosophy is literature does kind of
exist at the time that socrates
is in you know teaching all of his
his uh friends and students you know he
mentions annex agaris
buying his scrolls reading through them
and saying well this is
this isn't true you know so you know
we also have an entire literature
generated
around this guy socrates right i
mentioned platonic dialogues
xenophon's dialogues there's all sorts
of other stories
told about him in which he appears as
kind of the prototypical
philosopher and by observing these we're
supposed to learn
what philosophy as activity consists in
and we can say that for the later
discipline of philosophy
philosophies you find it in academic
departments and textbooks and
things like that socrates is at least
referenced if not always understood
um you know a lot of people will say oh
he's he's the guy who said
i i'm wiser than everyone else because i
know that i don't know anything and
that's that's the tip of the iceberg
with socrates but
you will find you know introductory text
talking about
his dictum the unexamined life is not
worth living and then moving on to other
things
what about another philosopher let's
think about rene descartes
considered to be one of the fathers not
only of modern philosophy but of
modernity
in general descartes himself
did write things he generates a
literature
um not a vast literature as a matter of
fact
harry fronkford a great 20th century
philosopher
said that one reason he became a
descartes scholar was because when he
was looking at the body of literature
that he would have to master he saw that
the cartesian corpus was
rather small and being inclined towards
laziness he decided i'll become a
descartes scholar
rather than you know taking on the
corpus of somebody who had much more
writings he may have been doing some
false humility
at that time but um descartes certainly
does generate a literature that we still
read today
he's also responding to the literature
of his time
the literature that he's engaged in
think about the
meditations on first philosophy what
follows that
objections and replies including from
some
very famous philosophers in their own
respect like thomas hobbs or pierre
gascendy
both of whom descartes didn't really get
along with right
descartes is displaying in that
literature a new way
of carrying out philosophical
activity he also is looking at the
university system of his time
and saying philosophy as a discipline
is in bad shape you know we need to
reform it and we reform it
by thinking about the activity and what
it would require you know moving away
for example from
you know the thinking about things in
terms of the body and into the the mind
freed from the body which we can only do
through
discipline this is where philosophy as a
way of life comes in
descartes sketches out
a way of living that was attractive to
many
people for example in the the play
cyrano de bergerac
right we find a point where cyrano
actually
says i'm going to read descartes why
because descartes was viewed as
providing
some path forward that one could
incorporate into one's life
and let's think about you know other
people maybe down the line we could we
could put them into this matrix and say
where do they fit in with us a few other
points i'd like to make that i think
could be helpful for wrapping your head
around this
so philosophy is a discipline it's been
around for a long time
there there's never been some absolutely
agreed upon standards or cannon
or motive organization and at the same
time
it's not you know well anything goes
in order to be academic philosophy
traditionally there has to be somebody
who's actually in the position of
a teacher a professor and they're
selected by
others and you could think of it as a
guild or a cast now in in recent times
of course
it's become professionalized but in
in a lot of different ways so what
counts as
you know meeting the requirements of the
discipline in
one college might not be the same thing
as in another college and so we have
this incredibly diverse
discipline going on that we
call philosophy with a lot of different
things under that
heading and it's often part of an
educational structure
in the middle ages philosophy
was what the in the west what the seven
liberal arts flowed into
and then philosophy was a stopping point
before you did your real degree
in law medicine or theology but there
were people who just practiced
philosophy as such in the discipline
just like there were people who
specialized in rhetoric
and now you know we have people who
get their masters or phds generally phd
if you want to teach because there's
there's so many people on the market
and they try to get jobs within the
university system maybe they're
successful maybe they're not
and then they contribute to the ongoing
development of that discipline a lot of
which is
you know teaching new generations in in
place
philosophy of literature vast amounts
right going all the way back into
antiquity
and this also includes not just the
original
language literature but also
translations alexander of aphrodisias
for example a great aristotelian
commentator who i'm a big fan of
most of his stuff was not translated
until recent decades into english so it
was largely
inaccessible the person he was
commenting on aristotle of course
translations have existed for you know a
very long time haven't they
more than a millennium there's a
vast philosophical literature out there
you can see this by going to libraries
or bookstores or going online
much of it is carried out in a variety
of different
genres ranging from poetry and drama
all the way to very abstract often
mind-numbingly sterile academic articles
and journals and everything
in between there is no absolute
agreement on where the boundaries of
philosophical literature lie
philosophy is an activity oftentimes
this can be tied in with
understandings of methodology or
starting points or the ways in which
we're supposed to be engaging in
philosophy
and it includes as i mentioned before
not just what you go off and do in your
room by yourself
but also what you do in relation to
other philosophers and
that may include going to the literature
and saying well what does
what does rene descartes what does
benedict spinoza what does
david hume what does mary wallstonecraft
have to talk to tell me
to teach me to throw in my face that i
need to then
react to and respond to and think
through you know partially accept
partially reject
or buy in wholesale uh finally
philosophy is a vocation or as a way of
life this is something
that we do see people practicing
in large part outside of academia
we live in an extraordinary time in
which the internet
has opened up access to
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
people to engage in philosophy as a way
of life outside
of the academic discipline but informed
by
the literature carrying out the activity
and occasionally coinciding with
philosophy as a discipline
so these are all important aspects of
philosophy
when somebody says philosophy is this
philosophy does this this person's a
philosopher this person isn't
you want to ask well what sense of
philosophy
do they have in mind and this might be
helpful for you
you